hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades
although fortnight Battle Royale gets
all the plaudits and rightfully so
the PvE fortnight games save the world
is also a bloody good game but it mans
hundreds of hours of grind
I've been casually playing for about a
year now but that all changed when epic
shoulders the Storm King I have to
double down and grind like a madman to
fight that beast if you just here for
the fight skip to this timecode to see
our battle but if you're interested in
the grind to the Storm King I'll quickly
recap now save the world is broken into
areas on the map are chapters if you
will the stonking fight is during the
third chapter known as canny valley to
get to the storm king we had to fight
tens of thousands of husks defend stomm
shields at our home base and go on so
many fetch quests for so many items that
yeah it did get a little tedious at
times so i went and found a friend who
was also trying to grind to get to the
storm king and i have to say it 100%
changes how you see the game this is a
social game play with other people if
you can whether you buy or wait until it
becomes free play it with others it's so
much better I can't reiterate that
enough personally the law is what kept
me coming back to save the world one
character I adore in Battle Royale
power cord is actually part of the story
in save the world and she sounds like
this straight Pete it's cool and I am a
hero I've been saving a lot of people
from the ghosty goolies back home thank
you very much everyone wants to be
traitor
save the world also taught me tons about
law such as rifts and the difference
between an alpha and a beta rift I'm
hoping to produce a breakdown of law in
the future because it's actually quite
compelling when you give it the time
even though yes it's still ridiculously
random anyway after 30 hours of grind we
finally made it to the portal and this
is what happened enter the bards all to
the portal here we go okay yeah boy if
we take out the storm king strike team a
will sit
you're the bomb and return to home base
most of strike team a then it's in the
hands that whoever stayed behind to
activate the bomb if we succeed we'll
live to fight another day
but if we fail then we've put up one
hell of a fight they're gonna do their
worst so let's do our best stay sharp
anything can happen over there stand by
to transport over to the other side
oh whoa okay that is that's pretty damn
epic that is pretty damn it I'm just
shooting no numbers appliances
oh I just got hit oh my God look at my
health from one hit
this is gonna be a long fight oh I look
so damn good
well builds a pointless
hey those dual ports are here I'm gonna
jump on one if I die
[Music]
come on Betty guy wrist guard they go
out there oh look at me just gone now is
awesome
no in on the obvious you've died I have
the last word survive again again come
on do it this time we know what to do
and we wasted so many materials right we
know this I'm going straight in there I
am getting funky throw away tomato as
soon as I see open to shoot I will shoot
it in the meantime I will give him a
dance
come on you big black
what we're shooting him open up chest
I am
yeah it's gonna make sure we don't get
knocked off the edge he's always gone
I've read every game this the other way
that one down
excellent work
yeah he's done for me
there we go and there we go
next one can use chest asked has fully
gone this time
there we go
that's all you Pope would've all right
thank you so much thanks anon it looked
good even if it didn't hurt see that's
what I was about site didn't do anything
but it looks awesome
oh it's so cool son I'm with you you're
with me there we go right listen
yeah I'm with you I'm flunking the crap
I'm a come on that's what
while about me being around just to
reinforce it so we don't fall down and
we supposed to do this test detects the
pond it's going red she said
I just do don't kicks it
my stash me too
on the day now there you go
the miss monsters
how long do I have to do this
did it done it right what's next
again gout yes he's waking up yeah got
the upper horns too
well now look at his lovely head right
we can do this we've got a system now on
a system oh man it's gonna get stronger
isn't it
she's gonna be hard now dude that was
the easy section come on you piece of
turd yeah thanks
you've got the perfect time going for
you coming up no almost I'm gonna go
away it's got one hit our dude knock me
down as well
[Music]
this is hard this is - I think we need
to do it - I was okay okay that's fine
yeah find another person four of us I'm
happy about this already
yeah I know right we all take a corner
each should be able to rinse this guy
every boom dude I'm so eating this I've
got to make sure I get out the way of
that one in the next round it's on his
left side again it's Tom oh yeah
gone I can melted him right side under
the ribs it's not my side I found help
with this
but I can dance right guys attention you
should be a rinse him off but I'm gonna
get crushed by those rock there we go
look at that
boom that seems pretty I'm going I'm
just building loads of reinforcement
there's the power bar on it this time
we're already halfway through it is that
that's awesome I'm doing with you oh
yeah good and it's done
brilliant work everyone else is awesome
this is where I want to be able to way
that's that's penny thing we need to be
in the air on those little projectiles I
think
yes when you play like less than a team
of four you can cater for that with a
defender and by building lots of traps
whereas you don't have down here
get into it this is cool this
tensions on me epic game for this place
yeah because I think that places they
have to this kind of mode is encampments
they need war just fighting imagine if
this had my areas you have to stand at
the same time you know like a destiny
bomb yes yeah yeah you know it just
needs leveling up a little bit more well
maybe there is more we haven't got to
the final stage of it yeah please I'm
sure you've noticed this is a bracelet I
go hitting it about a quarter of its
health has gone already
oh my word Miami's all over the shop you
can tell it's two o'clock in the morning
oh we gonna let some big uns down go go
go with your pigs
alright I'm building up and connecting
you keep doing it
yet as a massive smasher done no power
borrowing at this time so we just swing
freedom
Roth joining 8 well done let he's gonna
help whoo yeah yeah one of those he
looks annoyed we rap Stosh this is the
move which killed is in one shot left at
with the bag let's do this why are you
just gonna see him
I'm doing an astroid on him
yes trucks ever gonna work it's now
[Music]
hey look it's the queue it's Kevin my
scrapple the evilly oh my word no Kevin
whoa
I enjoyed that dude I really did that
was awesome
even though that was a lot faster paced
yeah I was good deep that was worth the
30 hours of grind that was the storm
King and that's how to beat him we took
was a bit of a while to figure out that
we had to actually pickaxe his horns but
we got there in the end
and it was quite a nice fight definitely
need four people though
anyway we got a go so miles would you
like to advertise yourself dude why not
this is your chance to shine
go on fella my name on YouTube is just
my name Myles Dyer so you can go to
youtube.com forward slash Myles my le s
and in terms of the type of videos I do
I'm currently in the early stages of
making a new podcast show only a few
episodes are up it's called the quest
for empathy long-form conversations more
serious but there is a lot of laughs in
there as well
and they'll no doubt be some gaming
topics in future episodes such as search
quest for empathy on YouTube or iTunes
thank you for let me plug Wow that was
it was like you wrote it beforehand but
that was definitely wasn't it yeah no I
had this massive light list of it I was
like oh here it is thank you very much
for your time thank you thank you if
you're still here and watching that was
this dog king I enjoyed it
what about you I imagine from
Playstation grenade and that guy was
miles and was the effects token
[Music]